most people are familiar with the
Rubik's Cube but very few of them have
actually solved it and that's because if
you don't know the moves the rubik's
cube is one of the most difficult
mainstream puzzles ever created frankly
the three by three by three is too hard
okay it really is now a lot of that has
to do with the fact that there are
literally billions of billions of ways
to scramble this thing but what's
equally incredible is that with a few
weeks of dedicated practice and a little
bit of memorization most people can
learn to solve any of those scrambles in
a few minutes but there are some people
who can solve it even faster a lot
faster they're called speed cubers and
the best of them can whip a rubik's cube
into shape in well under ten seconds is
if that weren't impressive enough the
single fastest solve ever recorded in
competition is a ludicrous three point
four seven seconds look at that time go
down today we're gonna look at by
solving a rubik's cube in under three
seconds is almost impossible to find out
what it takes I spoke to a world record
holder got a crash course in technique
from some local speed cubers now the
problem here is you notice that things
here on the edge don't match problem
here is that I don't even see that
that's a problem here and talked about
the mind-boggling math behind the cube
with a computer scientist there are more
positions on the Rubik's cubes and there
are grains of sand on all the Earth's
features the rubik's cube was invented
by hungarian architect Erno Rubik in
1974 it actually started out as an
experiment
Rubick wanted to know if it was possible
to design a cube made of smaller blocks
that can move independently without
falling apart it was only later that he
realized he'd also created a puzzle and
that puzzle got very popular it wasn't
long before people were competing to see
who could solve it fastest at the first
world rubik's cube championships in 1982
competitors took up to a minute to solve
the cube but speed solvers like world
record holder felix mpegs have been
chipping away at those times
ever since I think almost 100
competitions all around the world broken
a bunch of world records and won a bunch
of grudge
one round in competition consists of
five solve attempts a computer randomly
generates the scrambles to make sure
they're difficult enough and each
competitor solves the same five
scrambles you get asked are you ready
I'll take off the cover and then you
have option 15 seconds to look at the
cube and start the timer so you get that
time to look at it then you have to
place your hands down on the timer and
then fill the cube and then return your
hands to like the stack that timer now
is probably a good place to mention that
diehard cube roots actually care more
about average times than single solves
fact is sometimes you just get a lucky
scramble a better test of a speed cubers
skill is to have them solve five cubes
and average the three middle times zem
DAGs currently holds the average solve
record of five point six nine seconds
but single solve times still matter and
xem Dex used to hold that record too
with a time of four point two two
seconds that was until Chinese speed
cuber you Sheng do demolished it last
fall with a time of three point four
seven seconds so how unexpected was it
for somebody to come along and break
your single solve record by like 3/4 of
a second that was pretty unexpected to
be honest like in in speed cubing you
don't often see those sorts of insane
jumps in time you can still get a really
incredibly quick solve just on one
attention if you have an easy scramble
and a big block and it just so happened
that you know there's so many people
going to so many competitions all the
time that something like this was
probably bound to happen but we didn't
really expect it that soon okay so let's
put speed cubing aside for a second
because a lot of people myself included
have never solved the Rubik's Cube at
all in any amount and that's because
truly solving one like from scratch
without any help from anybody without
watching any online tutorial videos it's
really really hard the truth is if you
see somebody solving a Rubik's Cube
they are almost definitely using a
memorized sequence of moves to do it
this is Tyson Mao he's a co-founder of
the world cube Association and I asked
him to teach me the basics I would say
there are probably three things to think
about in terms of what makes someone
fast at solving the cube the first one
is the method there are many methods for
solving a cube but they all rely on
something that cubers call algorithms
memorize sequences of moves that players
use to solve the cube section-by-section
now as a rule of thumb the more
algorithms you know the fewer moves
you'll need to solve the cube a beginner
who has committed fewer than 10
algorithms to memory might solve a cube
and say 120 moves while an expert who
has memorized hundreds of algorithms can
solve the cube and closer to 50 or 60
moves and as you might expect fewer
moves can translate to faster solves the
second thing that contributes to is you
know how allah' teaches all the cube is
how fast you can turn the cube the
fastest speed cubers in the world
averaged around 10 turns per second over
the course of an entire song and a lot
more than that in shortened versions
take this 16 move finishing sequence for
example it looks like this 1 2 3 4 with
this ring finger 5 6 7 8 and now you
gotta push back with this ring finger 9
10 11 12 pull 13 14 15 16 push the top
people can execute those 16 moves in
under one second are you serious that's
amazing
the third thing that contributes to how
long it takes to solve the cube is how
long it takes you to processed
information it doesn't help you if it
takes you five seconds to figure out
what the next step is your goal is to
try to look ahead and see what the moves
for the next step are while you're doing
the current one and reducing a pause
between those steps and then there's the
hardware itself as you can see there are
lots of different types of 3x3 cubes
from the old-school version which was
clunky stiff and hard to turn to fancy
new models that spin with ease and
include tiny magnets to help the faces
snap into position the actual hardware
itself is involved to the point now
where it's like it's really really good
like if you give me a cube from five
years ago it's probably taking off like
a second off my sometimes if you're
going to be a good cube er back in the
day you had to learn how to make you
have to learn how to prepare a cube and
make it good
and so what that would involve is you
take the cube apart you know if they're
imperfections you might sand some of
those things down you lubricate it with
some silicone let it dry put it back
together every sticker
you know just attention on the screws it
was it was a big effort over time as
more manufacturers entered the space
cubes just got a lot better than quality
so the kids these days they don't know
how good they have it like the
improvement in the cube technology has
caused a change in some of these
economics that move that I showed you
earlier there was absolutely no way you
could make a turn with this fourth ring
finger the way that people turn the cube
in the you know the hand movements that
people use evolved as a result of cubes
getting better so Mau taught me a method
for solving the cube that he shows the
beginners following his instructions it
took me 45 minutes to solve the cube for
my very first I think if you spent the
next two weeks on this you probably get
your time down to about 90 seconds 90
seconds okay I'm gonna try to get to a
point where I can solve the cube
consistently using the method Tyson was
giving me today in under 90 seconds and
we'll see how is that actually so I took
my new cube and got to practicing in the
first few days I went from meeting
around 20 minutes to solve the cube to
just under three not bad for a newbie
but that's still an eternity for someone
like Tiffany TN a local speed cuber who
averages just under 10 seconds per solve
she's so good she can solve a cube
blindfolded and one handed just saw a
rubik's cube with one hand more than
three times faster than I can solve it
with you when you pick up a cube you
don't look the way I look when I pick up
a cube which is like it's manic
you are actually not going full-tilt oh
yes definitely
my hands can definitely move faster than
like my brain can during the solve so
it's limited not by how fast my hands
can move then like what my brain can see
what my eyes can see so are you
exercising that kind of restraint
throughout the entirety of it solve so
my
in competition is definitely to like
solve it as smoothly as possible like
with no pauses because I find that if I
try to turn quickly when I'm nervous
I'll turn very poorly I had her critique
my solving damn as a slow one one minute
41 seconds I'm ashamed okay so do you
have any tips based on that for starters
she said I should try opening with a
more efficient move the second tip is
more general for the entire self I
noticed that you spend a lot of time
like turning the whole cube around or
like using your whole hand to turn the
cube around so like during while you're
doing the second there you see the piece
up here so you go like this or something
but you can see pieces that are like on
the other side of the cube so you
shouldn't need to do so many rotations
of the whole cube so given what we've
learned about speed cubing what is the
lower limit how fast can we go to figure
that out it helps to understand some of
the math behind the cube and for that we
turn to computer scientist Tom Rick
Hickey
there's forty-three billion billion
musicians which is 43 quintillion right
so it's really a big number
Ruki key has been fascinated with the
cube ever since he was a kid
and around the turn of the millennium he
started puzzling over one of the great
unanswered questions of the cube and
this is a little confusing at first but
stick with me of those 43 quintillion
configurations there are some of them
like this that are very easy to solve if
I handed you the cube in this state
you'd know that it takes just one moon
to resolve it but most of the scrambles
on the tube are a lot more complicated
than that
so the question Ricky wanted to answer
was this what is the maximum number of
moves that would ever be required to
solve you no matter how scrambled it is
mathematicians call that figure godness
and it went unknown
more than 30 years until rick hickey and
his colleagues figured it out we used a
really fast program with all sorts of
clever tricks that let us solve about a
billion positions a second and then we
used a billion seconds of computer time
now a billion seconds of computer time
sounds like a long time and really it is
except for if you've got thousands of
computers it's a lot less so what is
God's number when it comes to the
Rubik's Cube 20 no matter how
complicated this scramble gets you are
never more than 20 moves away from being
completely solved and it's usually less
than that almost all positions require
fewer than 20 moves 18 is the most
common so your typical scramble you're
going to get from your timer it's going
to take a team moves to solve optimally
now you'll remember that the fastest
speed cubers on earth averaged about 10
turns of the cube per second you divide
God's number which remember is never
more than 20 by 10 turns per second and
you get solved times of under two
seconds and look here's proof that it is
physically possible to solve one in that
time in fact this robot can solve it in
under one second so from a purely
mathematical standpoint a sub two-second
solved by a human should be possible
there's just two problems with that line
of thinking
first of all just because a computer can
quickly identify the fewest number of
moves to solve a cube doesn't mean a
human can magic there's nobody out there
that can look at this cube and say ah
I'm eighteen moves from solved and this
one takes me to seventeen that's just
not something which humans can do in
second even if a human could look at
acute and quickly identify the fewest
number of moves required to solve it
there's no telling whether performing
that sequence of moves would be any
faster than their usual technique that's
because there can be a trade-off between
the number of moves it takes to solve a
cube and the speed at which you can
execute those moves ultimately solving
the cube requires executing finkles
physical moves and the faster that you
can execute those moves the less time it
needs to solve the cube but it's not as
simple as minimizing the number of moves
it is not you know ergonomics and other
things come into play so one example is
you know this state which we
you notice that there are three stickers
here that are not solved we call this
case the u permutation and originally
when people were solving this there is a
nine move sequence that that looked like
this and this is how people solve the
cube but then over time I want to say
around 2004 2005 an 11 move sequence
became more popular because it was just
faster to execute you know you want to
minimize the number of moves but you
also want to be to make those moves
quickly so what do speed cubers think
the limits actually are people have
asked me to speculate what the road
record will eventually reach and every
time I speculated I've been wrong so
I'll take another shot at it again you
know you know I think low fives is
probably at least from an average you
know maybe five flat as for the limits
of a single salt in the next five years
I would expect probably something under
three seconds given just enough chances
on my fist and the single sold time in
practices like 301 but then there's a
couple people who've done like on day
three at home again just pretty much
different I look like probably I could
do it to 25 but it's just when will it
happen faster times will come down to a
combination of luck
improvements in hardware the development
of more efficient methods in smoother
execution as for me for two weeks
I brought a Rubik's Cube with me
everywhere I went the practice at least
20 minutes a day I got my single solved
I'm down to 59 seconds and my best 5
solution average down to one minute 8
seconds so actually made a ton of
progress and you probably could too well
I'm never going to compete with any of
the world's fastest speed solvers that's
totally fine because what they're doing
is already almost impossible
[Music]